[Applaudissements]
voyez cette famille elle heureuse dans
sa voiture ils feraient mieux de
regarder la route vous me direz mais bon
de toute façon même s'il regardait la
route qu'il serait incapable de
percevoir qui sont en train de foncer
droit dans un mur
cette famille c'est vous c'est moi c'est
la société
ce mur mais elle incarne l'ensemble des
crises qui sont en train petit à petit
de fracturer la société crise
environnementale
on est rentré dans la sixième grande
extinction de masse des espèces les
poissons meurent dans les océans à cause
du plastique les forêts rétrécissent
parce que l'on doit nourrir le bétail
qui finira dans nos assiettes crise
sanitaire
on constate autour de nous de plus en
plus de personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques
nous les hommes on a perdu 50 % de notre
fertilité en 50 ans
crise sociale quand on est jeune on a du
mal à trouver un travail
et quand on a un travail et bien on
souffre de plus en plus ont dépéri ou
burn out ça vous tenez le coup vous
inquiétez pas ça ira mieux ça ira mieux
après mais malgré l'importance de ces
enjeux 1 pour nous et la société on
constate pas un engagement massif des
citoyens pour faire en sorte que l'on
change de direction continue de vivre
notre vie comme si le mur qui était en
face de nous il n'existait pas et a
raison car la particularité de ce mur
c'est qu'il est invisible
est ce que vous entendez une alarme qui
sonne chez vous à chaque fois qu'une
espèce disparaît parce que vous recevez
une décharge électrique à chaque fois
qu'un enfant meurt d'un cancer
non jamais on est très peu affectée au
quotidien et malheureusement l'histoire
nous démontre que l'humanité ne s'est
échangé que quand il est dos au mur et
donc dans la souffrance
moi ce que j'aimerais ce dont je
rêverais c'est que pour une fois nous
puissions changer dans la joie alors
comment faire
je vais raconter une histoire à la fois
personnel et collectif qui m'a permis de
comprendre quelques clés pour susciter
autour de moi l'envié et le plaisir
d'agir alors l'envi d'agir se déclenche
souvent par une histoire personnelle
moi mon déclencheur ça a été ma famille
mon grand père est mort d'un cancer des
poumons
ma grand mère un cancer du colon mon
père à la maladie de parkinson
ma mère a la maladie de crohn
quand on a la maladie comme ça autour de
soi on a deux possibilités soit on se
résigne en disant qu'on a un patrimoine
génétique tous pourris sur kindle tu
vois ça tu next direct soit tu
t'indignes et j'ai choisi cette option
j'ai bien fait car je me suis rendu
compte que la crise sanitaire dont ma
famille a été victime comme beaucoup
d'autres étaient pas lié à un mauvais
patrimoine génétique elle était liée à
une pollution généralisée de notre
environnement
l'air que l'on respire l'eau que l'on
boit la nourriture que l'on mange les
vêtements que l'on porte tout ça est
polluée ce qui est insupportable c'est
de comprendre qu'une grande partie de
ces maladies pourraient être évités par
une meilleure réglementation des
entreprises et une meilleure
sensibilisation des citoyens et c'est à
cela que j'ai décidé de mettre mon
énergie
et c'est là où l'histoire collective
commence on est en 2010 je viens
d'intégrer une association l'appel de la
jeunesse qui vise justement à
sensibiliser les jeunes du lien entre la
dégradation notre environnement et notre
état de santé
on n'a jamais réussi à démobiliser elle
était restée beaucoup trop écolo
beaucoup trop chiant et en 2012 avec
deux amis on décide de reprendre
l'association de la moderniser mais
surtout d'opérer une rupture totale avec
les modes de mobilisation et de
sensibilisation de ces dernières
décennies en matière d'écologie
jusqu'à présent à les écologistes ont
compris étions tellement persuadé un de
la juge
et noble cause que l'on défend dès que
l'on s'attache est plus au fond du
discours qu'à la forme et que même notre
propre image
on a sonné pas si je vous demandais pour
vous un écolo qu'est ce que c'est c'est
quelqu'un de bien relou qui ne se lavent
pas et qu'il ya plein vol par tous temps
vous dire que c'est absolument pas comme
ça que l'on donne envie aux gens de
s'engager
on avait oublié quelque chose de
fondamental c'est que les hommes et les
femmes agi sous la pression de deux
grandes forces
alors oui à la force rationnel alors ça
les écolos on sait faire c'est apporter
les chiffres des preuves du concret mais
la force qu'il faut activer en premier
lieu si vous voulez mobiliser les gens
c'est pas la force rationnelle c'est la
force émotionnelle c'est le beau le cool
le drôle et la clé pour pouvoir les
mobiliser de manière efficace c'est de
pouvoir activer les deux forces de
manière équilibrée
prenons un exemple soir de ce que vous
démontrez votre prend l'exemple du
jimani france pas parce que vous
démontrez rationnellement l'intérêt
d'acheter angie de made in france
parce que moins de co2 pas de travail
des enfants meilleur impact économique
en local que l'ensemble des gens vont se
ruer pour l'acheter si dans un premier
temps vous n'avez pas susciter le désir
autour de cet objet à travers sa coupe
ses couleurs
seuls des plus convaincus l'achèteront
et on ne sera pas plus avancé mais une
fois que vous avez suscité le désir
autour de l'objet le fait de proposer à
jean made in france avec tous les
arguments rationnels ma cela renforce la
vie de la personne de l'acheter c'est là
que jamais d'une deuxième clé qui est
qu'une fois que vous avez donné l'envié
aux gens d'agir il ne faut surtout pas
que ceci se retrouve face à des
difficultés pour passer à l'action
ce qui implique que dans toute action
visant à modifier les comportements des
gens il faut que vous puissiez apporter
dans le même temps
des solutions qui soient à la fois
concrète et accessible
j'amènerai une troisième clé qui est que
si vous souhaitez que cet engagement
dure dans le temps il faut que les gens
prennent plaisir à agir s'ils ont leur
engagement s'estompera donc pour résumer
pour pouvoir toucher notre cible en
l'occurrence les jeunes nous fallait
trouver une action qui active à la fois
la force émotionnelle et rationnelle de
l'individu apporte des solutions
concrètes et accessible et soit source
de plaisir alors autant vous dire que le
challenge était élevé un nom est arrivé
on est en 2012 on vient de reprendre
l'association il nous fallait trouver
une entrée qui soit suffisamment
attirante pour parler de pesticides
perturbateurs endocriniens de gm va tout
s'est joué très anxiogène alors moi
j'aime le tennis extrême clivant j'aime
le cinéma
alors pour trouver un sujet c'était
compliqué et je suis très vite arrivés à
la conclusion que la seule entrée
possible qui soit fun qu'ils ne soient
présents que ce gène qui soit source de
plaisir universel mais cette entrée
c'est l'entrée par le cul le sexe est
qu'avec ce thème mais il me suffisait
plus que de l'enrobé de tous ces sujets
anxiogène et pour ça j'ai imaginé un
parcours de la drague en sept étapes de
la masturbation à la pénétration qui
vous fait passer d'un orgasme minable et
pathétique
celui que vous avez peut-être
actuellement un orgasme durable et
visionnaire les corps gaz
alors pour que je vous montre quand même
des commandants qu'est-ce qu'ils sont la
promesse de l'ecc organe c'est se faire
plaisir sans se faire de mal ce que les
calmes dans un monde complètement fou ou
vouloir une partie de jambes en l'air
nous expose divers stades de pollution
on commence un au célibat vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux et nombreuses à
vous masturber avec des sex-toys rempli
le phtalate
jusqu'à la pénétration on va s'étaler
les parties génitales de lubrifiants
plein parabènes qui sont des
perturbateurs endocriniens et entre ces
deux étapes
bahia un parcours de la drague plus ou
moins classiques que l'on va suivre
on va se maquiller pour se faire belle
et puis c'est aller dans la phase des
nanoparticules récupère un numéro sexto
t s'exposer aux ondes
puis c'est d'avoir un premier d'haïti
tourna vers touba plat et se remplir
l'estomac de pesticides etc etc
et à chaque fois ce qu'on essaye
d'apporter des solutions qui soient
concrète et accessible
si je prends par exemple le commandement
7 une pénétration sans perturbateurs
endocriniens tu testera pénétration
force émotionnelle sur ceux de plaisir
ok on explique pourquoi c'est important
et on propose une solution vous la
prochaine fois que vous irez chercher
votre lubrifiants il vous suffit de
regarder sur l'emballage s'il a écrit la
mention sans paraben
résultat aujourd'hui on est des milliers
de jeunes bénévoles répartis sur toute
la france on tourne des centaines de
milliers de jeunes chaque année sur les
sujets très anxiogène mais on est encore
trop peu à être sensibilisés nous faut
sans cesse se trouver de nouvelles
nouvelles idées nouveau projet pour
donner à l'écologie une image fun et
positive seule condition pour nous
éviter ce mur dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure je m'appelle timothée lequel
je suis le co fondateur du mouvement
générations cobayes
est ce que j'aimerais vous dire avant de
vous laisser
c'est que chacun d'entre vous puissiez
trouver un combat qui vous tiennent à
coeur
un combat qui soit profitable pour la
société et que vous puissiez utiliser
ces quelques clés que je vous ai partagé
pour susciter autour de vous l'envié et
le plaisir d'agir
merci